we're playing a bunch of battlefield
we're having a lot of fun games hella
busted it's hovercraft to field
look this game's got a lot of problems
at launch we're totally aware of that
we're driving hovercrafts up the sides
of buildings and having fun doing a lot
of broken stuff right now but what we
want to do in this video is what we love
to do with battlefield which is kind of
test the sandbox see what specialists
can do what they can't do if you want to
suggest anything that we try after this
video we would love to just keep doing
the series because we love battlefield
so please join us hit that thumbs up hit
that subscribe button and let's get to
testing battlefield 2042 all right so
the first test that we wanted to try was
can you drop a vehicle to kill an enemy
player especially a pesky enemy sniper
i've wanted to know that ever since i
did it to myself accidentally
so the answer is clearly yes we did that
in our intro the question is also now
can you do with like angel's beacon if
you happen to catch somebody off guard
so
this is
oh i went off the edge on that one
confirmed you can definitely kill
players by dropping
you can definitely kill players by
dropping vehicles on them and also with
angel's beacon so the next test in the
beta people could heal by just shooting
the ground and i want to see if that's
still a thing so give me a couple shots
try not to kill me
just mortally wound me
oh it totally worked do it again
yep that totally works now
um so
if you are playing as faulk and you take
a hit if you do the self heal it takes a
while like hit me at me real quick
okay so self-heal is this whole like
process right
but if somebody just
hit me again
and
fire at the ground yep firing at the
ground is way more effective than just
doing the self heal one more time so
sure can i tell you what i just saw from
my side because it looks
so it looks like you're shooting like a
cartridge out
and you're basically walking over it so
try try shooting it like a little bit in
front of you and then walking over it
and see if that works too
okay hit me and then yeah and then
nothing no nothing nothing oh it's the
new stickiness
totally safe
it's literally you're literally shooting
out what looks like a uh like it's like
i can see it on the ground even so shoot
me a little bit and then shoot the dart
on the ground and see if i can take
advantage of it
okay let's try it one two yep
and then grab it yep i just healed okay
let me try something else too then while
we're here i'm gonna see if i can kill
you with this
is that hurting or yeah yeah that's
hurting healing
all right so that is two tests in one
confirmed that when folk shoots the
ground it's way faster than self-healing
but just as effective because you're
walking over your own darts which you
can see on the ground confirmed that an
enemy player can walk over those darts
and get healed but also confirmed that
if you shoot those darts directly into
another player they die so
this one this one is like the behavior
of these darts is all over the place but
that's actually really interesting to
know okay so something that came from
battlefield 3 is there were certain
instances where you could hide your
scope glint and we were curious if you
could hide scope glint from sniper
rifles behind irish's shield so david if
you want to drop a shield and pull out a
sniper rifle we can test this one out
all right
hit me with that scope lint
oh i'm not even seeing scopeline do you
have a high power scope
uh
you do should be
that is i don't even see any scope link
coming out of you right now
what is going on no scope when is it
only like you have to be far away
okay wow so that is okay just keep keep
aiming at me keep aiming me so we
started trying to test one thing but now
we're seeing another thing
so scopeland disappears when you get
close to somebody well that's
interesting
we weren't even trying to test that but
check this out turns out that
uh scope glint is by distance
so if you get really really close to
uh enemy players using sniper rifles you
won't see their scope clip that means if
you're close to somebody else with a
sniper rifle like hiding in a bush
you also won't see it okay so go ahead
and drop irish shield so the test that
we wanted to do at first here was
to see if irish's shield
blocks copeland okay so
irish's barricade
does seem to block it can you see me
through the barricade
i can see you through the bear kid i
can't shoot you though
so that's interesting so something that
you can do potentially here because this
is
uh this test is definitely confirmed
that irish's barricade
block scopeland you just pop up and fire
and then you pop back down let's give it
a try
yep totally works
so that test is confirmed irish's
barricade gets rid of your scope lint so
if you are a crafty sniper
um just go ahead and use irish's
barricade so people don't spot you right
away can dozer shield stop a rocket hit
me hit me with a rocket
wow
yeah all right that's impressive let me
aim at your uh at your feet oh you will
totally kill me if you hit me in the
feet oh really okay
i'll try to crush
okay now i'll try it on you
pop out your shield
now the shield's back
just just nowhere you did
you just made yours a rocket
okay
i'm gonna hit you with it and then i'm
gonna hit your feet okay
definitely stops a rocket
i i have a strong suspicion
your feet will die but let's try it
yep yeah
the physics bad
okay so that that test is definitely
confirmed um dozer shield can in fact
stop a rocket do you want to up the ante
and try hitting me with a helicopter
oh okay
yeah
here we go it
is so we'll test if dozer shield can
take rockets from vehicles
see if you can just get me right in the
right in the shield
god damn it
i took a solid hit i just go to the
ground
we'll try it let's try let's try a tank
round fire when ready
dang
did my glass break nope didn't break try
again
dozer can straight up
tank a tank that is
ridiculous
well that's a that's definitely
confirmed
dozer can tank a tank i'm starting to
take splash damage it's because you're
hitting the ground
yeah i'm hitting the ground
but my blast resistance kicked it
hit me again
can roadkill still confirmed
okay so for our next test you know when
you're playing the game and you keep
getting those messages that you're
taking vehicle specific damage you want
to hop in there david so we're gonna go
ahead and test what that actually means
it's we're really curious if you can
actually knock out a turret or um
knock out vehicle specific parts or if
that's just the message that you're
getting this is a bad spot to be i aim
to the side a little bit i'm gonna try
and shoot your top gun out
so
hanging right there
and
did it just go through your date
i just whizzed right by all right let's
try again
wow there's no collision on top of the
tank
it's like the matrix
you know how we talked about parts being
broken all right let me try your main
gun
part disabled okay shoot not me but just
shoot
yeah that took about like 25 damage
on the
on the entire tank health
it said park disabled though so like can
you not shoot any of your guns uh i can
shoot that fine i can shoot this fine
i can do the smoke
yeah i know i am my tank is perfectly
okay
okay let me try one more time
oops i'm gonna have to go oh it says
parts disabled again and
so i i'm noticing on the uh
i'm noticing on the tank there's red
markings now like on the top in the in
the back of the tank but it's not
actually affecting anything let's go
ahead and drop a like a recon vehicle
something a little bit lighter and we'll
go ahead and try this again
so actually you know what this time all
i'll go ahead and get in
um and because you have the rockets so
try not to kill me like try hitting the
back tire or something like that
backside sure yeah
hopefully they will die instantly
yeah
disabled
that's interesting oh no it's definitely
not disabled i mean like oh so you're
right like in the bottom of the screen
it's showing that the tires are are
damaged can you try shooting shooting
the tires with your gun
nothing
hit him with another rocket
it says so you got parts disabled
yep
all right well i'm i'm calling
shenanigans on this one this one's
busted um you're getting the message
that the parts are disabled but there's
no
there's no parts being disabled this
test is about rao so whenever you're
hacking things with a route he starts
saying that he can hack a vehicle
specific parts so we're gonna see if we
can disable
anything disarm weapons
so he says i'm disarming weapons
can you do specific weapons you know and
i was wondering if you could do vehicle
specific parts so let me um
go and hack
and says you're hacked okay now shoot
uh i cannot okay so we're gonna test if
rao can disarm specific weapons on a
helicopter because we keep getting this
message we're disarming weapons so i'm
gonna hack you and
go ahead and try and shoot
nope no shooting no flares
let me
swap to the gunner spot too let me swap
to the gunner spot let's give it a try
yeah hack it again
uh your firewall give me just one second
so it was interesting um there wasn't
any vehicle specific damage even though
we were getting those messages but so
far rau is getting accurate messaging on
kind of what he's doing to vehicles so
if it says he's disabling weapons right
now
yeah it's not working
that's awesome okay so like rao does
have some specific messaging that's
accurate
oh is it
i guess we are going to test collision
detection
and i would say that's busted on on
helicopters
i want take off
let's see keep going
well there you go um if you're on the
helicopter yeah
if you're wondering if there's any
collision detection for helicopter rotor
blades that is busted there's no
no collision detection for helicopter
rotor plates
we're gonna test if mckay can grapple a
rocket
this is gonna be interesting
three
two
one go
i think i grappled your rocket launcher
how did i kill you
uh let's let's test back blast actually
hang on so
we don't have a lot of shots here but
okay just fire the rocket three two
way on sorry
false alarm
three two one fire
back blast
continue
we weren't even trying to test back
blast there is back blast in battlefield
2042.
that's really funny
three two one fire
hmm i don't seem to be able to grapple
the rocket i can't confirm this one um
let me try over your shoulder one last
time and then i think we'll call this
one
okay ready
zooming right here okay
yeah
three two one fire
i don't think you can grapple a rocket
although this one
might not be confirmed or like busted
just because it's really hard to do but
in the course of this test we did
confirm that there's back blast which is
actually kind of cool okay well we hope
you guys enjoyed our initial battlefield
at 2042 tests there's probably a lot
more we can do a lot more we haven't
thought about with uh specialists and
their gadgets so if you guys can think
of anything else you want us to test in
the episode let us know while you're at
it head on over to gamespot.com youtube
page because we got a lot more
battlefield to cover we're also covering
a bunch of halo or if you're a call of
duty vanguard fan we have reviews of
that as well alright
thanks for watching everybody
did it land on top of you oh it's up
above you i was trying to drop that on
your head look up
we i think we picked we picked the worst
possible starting spot
we're not going to pretend like this
game isn't having problems
how is it going everybody uh aaron
sampson here with
david ahmadi yeah yeah you're david
ahmadi we've been uh
oh my god oh
my god